scientists in kenya italy and germany
have for years been tirelessly working
together to save the northern white
rhino from extinction
but there have been obstacles with a
pandemic affecting one of the most
important conservation projects in the
world and after several failed attempts
to harvest a number of immature eggs
known as oocytes
finally there was a breakthrough in
december 14 eggs were harvested from
fatu one of the last two remaining
northern white rhinos on earth
it was the highest number we ever got
from a rhino
and we were extremely happy about that
outcome and uh
on christmas eve two emperors were
frozen so
that we really add another two embryos
to our
already existing three embryos all five
embryos are now stored in liquid
nitrogen in a lab in
italy the scientists are looking at ways
to implant the embryos into a surrogate
mother a southern white
rhino after roaming in the wild for
millions of years the last remaining
northern white male named sudan died in
2018.
scientists saved his sperm and used it
to fertilize the eggs of his
granddaughter fatu
but neither fatu nor her mother najin
can carry a calf
and this is where a southern white rhino
comes in
we already done quite a few more a
little work with
using southern white embryos which are
less precious than the northern white as
a tool
to to understand and to develop the
procedures
so far out of 12 transfer we didn't get
a pregnancy
but we are understanding what are the
problems
the challenges don't stop there experts
say they don't have much time to save
one of the largest land mammals on earth
we have to produce a calf under the next
two three years
but right now we can't really work with
the northern mediterranean embryos
because we haven't proven that we can
produce a pregnancy
and therefore we're working with
infertile southern white rhinos
using this technology to helping them to
have a calf
and then get parallelly as a proof that
the emperor transfers the entire
cascade is successful one of the most
endangered species in the world
once roamed central africa in large
numbers but decades of poaching and
destruction of their habitat
led to their extinction in the wild
while the embryos raised hope
the process of saving the northern white
rhinoceros still faces
many challenges including whether a calf
born from this
process would even survive
al jazeera